hi guys welcome to another episode of
blog University thank you so much for
all of you participated in the last
wonderful blog University homework
assignment so last assignment was to
vlog your hidden talents now after
you're going through all of these videos
I kind of realized something you guys
have a lot of creepy talents first off
starting with this extremely creepy
eyelid flips I'm Lane vids yeah creeps
me out I can flip my eyelids it's really
easy to do to you then we go to this
creepy hand movement thang from snakes
and cakes and now to Luke 18 walking
around on his toes and now we have grey
James official kicking himself in the
head and this guy chirping like a
cricket and last but not least this
person is rolling with their foot and
another trend that I spotted is some
extremely musically talented people here
we have Felicia Mirage who's not only
extremely talented at playing the violin
she's also pretty good at the yo-yo this
is probably one of my favorites because
there's nothing that I love more than
people who can play the piano because
you guys are so awesome here's a song
with this girl composed herself
and of course our musical section here
would not be quite complete without
someone who can play the flute we also
have a few gymnasts in the house take 2
that means go again okay that's good now
that's not enough you artistic creative
types we have a face painter I can paint
my face without even looking at it and
model horse customization now not only
do we have someone who can customize a
model horse we also have some Google
dick and ride horses thank you guys so
much for all of your hard work that you
put into your last vlog University
assignments I had a great time grading
them okay watching your videos you guys
kind of made me feel like I'm not really
that talented I mean I cannot kick
myself in the head
okay all right maybe I can put your
assignment for the next vlog University
episode is going to be create something
out of food it can be anything it can be
a gingerbread house or a Halloween
gingerbread house we're gonna be putting
the roof on here very shortly know what
that means pick your tongues black that
is because i was eating oh I sorry Wow
they looked him up I'd you live it or
you could just draw on some food we go
draw a banana I tried to make a smiley
face thanks for watching and completing
your homework on time to submit a video
here for your homework assignments just
add a video response to this video and
yeah see you guys in the next episode be
sure to subscribe so you'll know when
the launch my video ok ok